traveling in style in a car fit for a
queen is a vintage Rolls Royce the name
alone conjures up pomp and pageantry and
the exterior of this British vehicle has
something regal about it
so it's little wonder that Montford
bushels 1962 Silver Cloud 3 turns heads
wherever they go and you month assault
mantra tells us that when people see the
car they stop and stare more than if he
were driving a VW Beetle people are
happy to see it and that's nice
he thinks it's great on phones ish
though that's true print Osgood the
rolls is hard - over here - with its
eight cylinder 200 horsepower engine the
Silver Cloud 3 has a top speed of 180
kilometers an hour
but man flat has never pushed his car to
the limit because his Silver Cloud is
strictly a pleasure vehicle it was built
in 1962 and then shipped to the US half
a year later it was registered in
California later the car returned to
Europe Monford purchased it in the
Netherlands in the year 2000
[Music]
[Music]
with its long hood and flowing lines the
silver cloud threes design is timeless
even today it's still an eye catcher
it's also over five meters long because
it was made for people who could afford
a chauffeur
you
[Music]
even Gustav the goose loves the rolls
it's hard to believe that Manfred
originally planned to buy another brand
of car I can fish what he says he
intended to purchase a Porsche and went
with his wife to the Porsche dealership
he was really excited because owning a
Porsche had been his childhood dream but
then he said to himself be sensible and
consult the internet first there he
found a table which listed car brands in
alphabetical order
not far under P for Porsche he saw our
four rolls-royce and this is what's come
of it this is his Porsche and he jokes
Manfred didn't find his own Silver Cloud
on the net but rather at a dealership
that was around 16 years ago and he's
kept a close eye on Emily
ever since them on here hidden Manfred
says when you sit back here and look
past the windshield wipers on the hood
you can see the winged figure of Emily
also known as the Spirit of Ecstasy he
feels that's a sight like no other it's
just great one that's not this is alpha
told Manfred bushel is also happy to
share that experience with others and
for really special occasions he has
something stowed away in the trunk a red
carpet that's enough to make anyone feel
like a VIP little details like this give
the car a character all of its own one
trip really stands out and man Fred's
mind
[Music]
I'm Isis Mia pasyati she says once he
was picking up a bride-to-be and her two
sisters the groom was already at the
church waiting for his bride when one of
the sisters started crying the tears
were flowing and she said I haven't got
a tissue my makeup will be ruined by
chance
Monford had some Kleenex in the glove
compartment so he handed her one and she
replied oh you're a real professional
he says driving wedding parties is just
nice and fun sure does much passant us
plus is this painter and sculptor
Charles Sykes created Rolls Royces
famous hood ornament he was commissioned
to create a figure that would complement
the elegant appearance of the brand's
cars Sykes described Emily as a graceful
little goddess and the spirit of speed
the fabric billowing from her
outstretched arms makes it look like she
has wings and is flying off into the
horizon
Monford vishal loves to sit behind the
wheel of his rolls and gaze at that
horizon even if he didn't get his
porsche mantra can't get enough of his
Silver Cloud 3 he wouldn't trade it for
any Porsche in the world
[Music]